Well, in this operation, we're copying some memory in to d_arr1.
We're operating in stream1 and then the kernel is launched in stream2,
so it can proceed immediately and operate on d_arr2.
Both of these operations will complete in 1 second. Everything's done in 1 second.
And this one is a bit of a trick question.
Once again, we have 2 operations. They're in different streams.
So it's correct to say that the final result will be completed in 1 second.
But hopefully you noticed that we're both copying some information into d_arr1
and at the same time, because we didn't wait to launch the kernel,
we're operating on d_arr1.
We're doing something with contents of d_arr1,
even as it's being overwritten by the cudaMemcpyAsync.
And so while it's true that we'll complete in 1 second,
we're going to get the wrong answer.